he is now being treated for serious
mental health problems but a week ago
Hugh Edwards didn't know what was about
to hit him and was talking to this times
journalist about his future I had no
idea no sense from that conversation
that he was in any sort of trouble at
all and I'm pretty convinced that he
didn't either have any inkling this was
why I was so astonished when his name
came out over the weekend not publicly
of course but within journalistic
circles because it didn't add up the the
man I just had lunch with was was not
the man being described in in these
allegations but it's emerged even before
the sun articles BBC journalists had
been looking into allegations against
their own presenter leading to Newsnight
reporting allegations from BBC staff
that Hugh Edwards had abused his power
sending inappropriate messages is it
legitimate to investigate the private
life of somebody with a high public
profile I mean his latest last night BBC
News night was running new allegation
against Hugh Edwards even after the
announcement that he was in hospital
so I don't think it's for broadcasters
to necessarily point the finger at
newspapers or vice versa I think all of
Journalism has to ask itself some quite
awkward questions media organizations
are always asking themselves not just
what their audiences want to know but
what they have a right to know and
what's private failures within a
publicly funded organization fall into
the right to know category but the
behavior of one of its top Stars well
that depends on the allegations the most
significant journalist on the BBC and
probably in the country who was uh had
one Public Image which is of a happily
married man with children with a strong
Church background he was secretly
associating with young people through
dating websites but even if proven true
that's not what caused the storm
questions for the Sun newspaper are when
it splashed this story on Saturday had
the alleged victim already told them it
was untrue the claims were repeated on
Sunday even though his lawyer says he
denied it on Friday what evidence did
reporters have to back the parents
assertion that the presenter paid for
explicit photos and then published the
parents claim the BBC had lied about
their knowledge of this the sun printed
other allegations but now say it wasn't
claiming criminality but that their
story was in the public interest if the
young person before publication did deny
that it happened and they didn't reflect
that in their article then they wouldn't
be able to it's likely rely on the
public interest defense
but the sun's journalism has left the
BBC investigating its highest profile
news reader and whether its own
procedures helped cause this crisis
Jason Farrell Sky News